alors
elle vous embrasse comme du bon pain
elle a fait une chanson contre le foot
dans son disque et j'ai entendu oui je
sais que toi je l'avais déjà entendu ça
c'est insupportable tous et samedis
soirs où on n'existent plus parce que
les mecs se vendent sont devant la télé
à regarder le match de foot à hurler j'y
crois pas j'y crois pas
si je peux donner un conseil de coach ça
tu devrai éviter ça alors faire chanter
ma chanson de cole ce que j'explique
qu'il faut finalement faire la poule et
que si on veut les dissuader de regarder
le foot il faut être très persuasive
voilà à quoi moi je commande des comptes
et les matchs de 5h15 way très
persuasive à 5h15 ça vous laisse le don
de soi mais
ça va ça va très bien oui alors guy roux
vous publié chez plon vos mémoires en
collaboration avec dominique grimault ça
s'appelle entre nous et là vous dit dès
le début du bouquin j'étais un gamin qui
avait tout pour être malheureux qui en
fin de compte a été heureux oui c'est
vrai
les conditions objectives de mon enfance
pendant la guerre père prisonnier et
cetera alors vous êtes né en 1938 à
colmar et 1938 c'est une année de coupe
du monde en france et vous assister à
votre premier match de foot dans le
ventre de votre mère c'était brésil
pologne c'est ça mais je me suis trompé
dans le score il ya on m'a téléphoné
pour me dire que c'était 6 à 5 et pas 6
à 5 pour un brésil dont le président
louis score de babyfoot ses défauts et
il
reste 11 villes de tennis alors l'année
suivante en 1939 votre grand-père qui
perçoit là la montée du nazisme dans
l'allemagne voisine emmène toute la
famille en bourgogne appoigny et là
pendant l'occupation la kommandantur
s'installe au château d'appoigny est en
fait c'est en voyant des allemands
jouaient au football sur la place du
village que vous commencez à aimer ce
sport oui puis l'instituteur aussi nous
emmener sur le sur le terrain de foot et
le dimanche les matchs de foot qui
n'était pas jouée par des allemands est
elle la seule distraction du village
donc on allait aussi voir les matchs de
fin le père est prisonnier à cette
époque il le sera jusqu'en 1945 c'est ça
il était dans un oeuf lag dans ce qui
est maintenant la tchécoslovaquie on va
la tchéquie ensuite votre père est
affecté en indochine
et c'est là que votre mère tombe malade
hémiplégique vous avez neuf ans
on m'a renvoyé en alsace chez des amis
parce que fallait s'occuper de ma mère
est là j'ai eu une chance je suis arrivé
l'année où les sports réunis colmar
était en première division ouais et là
je suis devenu tout de suite spectateurs
mais là reste un le dimanche vous
courrez 9 kilomètres pour assister à un
match
et vous devenez un ramasseur de balle
attitré du club quoi oui parce que quand
j'ai voulu entrer on m'a dit les enfants
non accompagnés n'ont pas l'aura
d'entrée alors j'ai attrapé un
imperméable et je me suis trouvé
accompagné vous cessez de croire en dieu
à l'âge de 13 ans quand vous
accomplissez à un pèlerinage pour guérir
votre mère et comme elle ne guérit pas
vous n'y croyez plus un ecclésiastique
vous avez mis un petit peu le marché
avait dit si tu fais le pèlerinage on
avait pas de portable pour savoir mais
quelques jours plus tard alors là
c'était une rupture
mais bon je ne suis pas devenu
anticlérical je me suis aperçu depuis
que la moitié de l'humanité croit en
dieu en un dieu et l'autre moitié n'y
crois pas mais je suis pas de ceux qui
pensent que l'autre moitié est idiote
coin on verra on verra
alors à 14 ans vous arrivez à auxerre à
l'aja auxerre et donc à l'époque vous
rêver encore de devenir joueur
professionnel
et en 1960 vous avez en angleterre pour
vous entraîner avec le crystal palace
jeu je faisais tous les concours pour
gagner un peu d'argent pendant les
vacances et là c'était un concours
officiel et j'étais étudier le sport en
grande bretagne en grande bretagne
j'étais le joueur numéro 29 à crystal
palace pendant un mois 1 à l'époque vous
croyez encore que vous aviez père c'est
quoi non non la cité était la limite
j'avais déjà demandé je pensais que je
n'y arriverai pas que j'arriverais page
houlette internationale et à limoges y
avait armand penverne qui est né qui
revenaient de la coupe du monde en suède
avec l'équipe de france j'ai dit si
j'arrive à être meilleur que lui je
continue sinon jatte dit pas assez
rapide pour devenir un grand show a dit
tétreault lang
faisait quand même joué jusqu'à l'âge de
34 ans oui j'ai même j'ai joué très très
tard j'ai fait mon dernier match à 57
ans à quart d'heure
mais bon j'ai joué dans l'équipe
d'auxerre au début j'étais entraîneur
joueur c'était dur à prendre la décision
de ne plus jouer non non c'était je m'en
étais déjà aperçue que j'étais trop lui
ai simplement ils m'ont ils m'ont permis
de vérifier j'ai eu la chance que
auxerre et besoin à ce moment là d'un
entraîneur et j'ai posé ma candidature
j'ai pu être embauchés ce moment là
alors ensuite vous raconter la saga
d'auxerre donc surtout l'année et 78 79
vous dites c'est l'année béni d'abord il
ya le film coup de tête de jean jacques
annaud qui est qui tournait à auxerre 1
avec patrick dewaere avec notre équipe
comme un figurant et patrick dewaere
dans notre équipe ouais c'était je crois
deux ans avant sa mort et déjà jean
jacques annaud nous avait demandé de de
l'accompagner il allait manger tous les
soirs chez un joueur pourquoi de tout
seul
et puis c'est une année aussi de la
finale de la coupe de france oui alors
que nous étions en deuxième division et
amateurs à ce moment là il y avait des
amateurs dans la deuxième division tout
le monde travaillait j'ai été voir les
employeurs un par un pour qu'il me donne
une semaine pour préparer l'équipe y
avait plus de monde ce jour-là dans les
rues d'auxerre qu'au jour de la
libération dites vous oui je juge max
meynier il vient de disparaître
était venu faire l'émission les routiers
sont sympas auxerre il a fait l'émission
du toit de sa mercedes parce qu'ils
pouvaient plus avancer nous nous étions
ouverts à rueil veille de match et on
m'a dit après que il y avait plus
auxerre était noire de monde plus qu'à
la libération c'est vrai c'était le
grand déclic c'est là que j'ai commencé
à signer les autographes
en partant en vacances le pompiste m'a
demandé de signer jeudi mais ça y est
j'ai donné mon chèque non fourni signé
sur le papier d'à côté voilà en 1982
c'est la création du centre de formation
les quand même recruter des mecs comme
cantona
les deux boli et sert à quoi oui ferreri
ça fait rêver est arrivé avant la
construction du centre et il a habité
chez moi il était un peu le grand frère
de mon fils ouais là vous devenez
éleveur de champions quoi oui c'est de
l'une des deux l'une des deux
appellations années plus tard les
guignols et voulait revendre et ça
permet d'acheter des biftecks aux autres
qui suivent c'est ça le système
d'auxerre je donne dans la musique
alors c'est l'époque évidemment c'est la
légende mais l'époque où vous vérifiez
les compteurs kilométriques de vos
joueurs pour savoir s'ils sortent le
soin pas tout à fait la légende je les
fais longtemps jusqu'à ce que les
voitures modernes n'affiche plus les
kilomètres
après j'étais obligé d'avoir des accords
avec les contrôleurs des péages
d'autoroute quand on est footballeur à
auxerre là la grande sortie c'est de
venir à paris
alors il avait trouvé la parade ils
visent à les prendre l'autoroute à
joigny ouais sauf que les gens de joigny
était avec moi aussi
mais il est très malin tu sais ce qu'ils
faisaient il a fait retarder un avion
d'air france pour avoir votre joueur
attend dans la finale benjani qui du
zimbabwe devait aller jouer contre le
gabon le lendemain harare spa côté faut
passer par johannesbourg et la finale
devait finir à trente
22h30 elle a fini à 37 et l'avion était
à 23h10 alors il aurait presque été à
l'heure mais tout d'un coup ma dia
contrôle antidopage il peut pas partir
ce qu'un joueur qui part et qui est tiré
au sort et des suspendus deux ans si les
voilà d'accord qu'on l'a retenu ensuite
aidé partir en moto est bon j'ai eu des
complices soient là mais la direction
d'air france avaient refusé ouais
m'avait dit on a retardé une fois un
avion pour le président de la république
on a eu une page dans le canard enchaîné
donc on peut pas retarder un avion
j'étais étonné parce que l'été précédent
j'étais allé à la guadeloupe et on était
parti trois heures en retard parce
qu'ils avaient tabassé l'hôtesse il ya
plusieurs façons de retarder les avions
eh bien je vais appeler qui va
l'entourage du pilote pour faire
retarder la vie au pilote m'a dit moi je
pars quand on dit parti voilà avec alors
il a fallu remonter la filière quoi un
malin il est malin ce bo5 tu lui dis que
je martiniquais
il dit qu'il est martinique et la
guadeloupe est arrivé l'avion pour aller
la guadeloupe s'arrête et indiqué et
voilà
0 on apprend en lisant votre bouquin
giggs est un grand superstitieux un jeté
ce que la fleur jaune par exemple chaque
fois que vous avez dans un endroit vous
cherchez oui les jours de match il
fallait je trouve une fleur jaune le
matin en faisant mon foot y est mais
pratiquement je croyais pas qu'il y
avait des fleurs toute l'année on arrive
à trouver des petites fleurs jaunes dans
les plus dans les champs ou dans les
bords de route et vous mettiez votre
voiture toujours à la même place sur le
parking c'est exact mais bon on me l'a
réservé on me lagarde est pour que je
puisse la mettre il ya une anecdote très
très troublante dans votre bouquin c'est
ce type qui vous appelle pour donner les
résultats oui hein
un homme qui m'a appelé un jour une
année on était bien classés on mettait à
cette pointe paris saint germain en 96
et il me dit il ya deux matches cette
semaine paris saint germain a rencontré
deux derniers du classement
et toi tu joue deux matchs et paris
saint germain ne prendra qu'un point sur
ces deux matches et toi tu vas gagner
deux matches ce sera plus qu'à deux
points de et alors paris saint germain
recevait martine qui était dernier et a
perdu 3 1 et puis ensuite il recevait
lille ils menaient 1 à 0 à quelques
minutes de la fin et un joueur de lille
complètement de la ligne de corner a
voulu faire un simple peut-être la
manquer il est passé entre le bras de
l'ama et le poteau il est entré est bon
alors cet homme l'avait ensuite elle m'a
dit moi je dirige les avec mon mental je
dis je les ballons si tu veux tu sera
champion alors on a fait un petit pari
avec
quelques quelques liquides de ma région
et
on a été champions et puis dans le mois
d'avril il ne peut pas gagner la coupe
aussi avis oui bien sûr dit il remet
quelques bouteilles bien sûr il me dit
je viendrai le lendemain de la finale la
coupe chez toi ou du championnat de
bonheur tu me donneras sa jérémy les
bouteilles de côté et on a gagné on a
fait doubler le doublé c'est très rare
il y en a eu que neuf dans l'histoire de
france du football et lyon par exemple
n'y arrive pas évidemment après les
venues de les emmener en coupe d'europe
mais alors c'est ce que j'ai dit je veux
aussi gagner la coupe d'europe il
faisait le tour du car j'avais du quart
adverse j'avais monté
et puis un jour ça n'a plus marché fort
c'est un mythe et christophe thomas
rabou c'est oui enfin c'était un homme
du sud ouest
on peut il pensait qu'il avait un
pouvoir alors peut-être qu'il m'avait
persuadé que j'avais une parce qu'un
entraîneur son métier c'est de persuader
les joueurs ça étonnant cette histoire
non oui bien sûr ça m'a toujours
intrigué et depuis j'ai plus jamais
rencontré quelqu'un comme ça alors j'ai
eu des marabouts sénégalais qui m'ont
écrit qu'ils vont y en a un jour qui m'a
dit qui m'envoyait un petit bout de bois
comme ça dans l' enveloppe il m'a dit tu
du le col dans le protège tibias de
franck silvestre qui n'a pas encore
marqué de but cette année il va marquer
alors une demi heure avant le match
j'étais avec un bout de sparadrap jdi
france a trahi le faire ça te dérange
pas
toute façon il a dit que tu marques
créent un but et bien il ya eu un corner
longtemps franck silvestre t bonds à la
tête mais la balle est tombée la marque
explique alors à prendre la garde et de
morceaux de bois mais la plus marquée
enfin chez nous parce qu'après la marque
et bouc
et alors le comptage coronarien c'est dû
à quoi c'est dû au stress peut-être
quelques petits excès alimentaires sains
le hasard est ce aussi sûrement
contrariété à l'époque voilà bon il a dû
à un double pontage coronarien sans
arrêt maladie quand même le seul mac
dans l'histoire de la sécurité sociale
ah oui c'est vrai le secrétaire du club
a oublié faire l'arrêt maladie est bon
aussi j'avais j'avais seize mois de
congés non pris ouais alors on n'était
pas un mois près alors vous dites dans
le bouquin que si c'était à refaire vous
vous seriez entraîneur mais à l'ombre
je serais parti vers l'âge de 40 ans
j'aurais réviser mon anglais scolaire
avec intensité
je serais parti en angleterre oui pour
deux raisons la première c'est qu'il ya
une ambiance de football formidable les
stades sont toujours pleins c'est
vraiment des gens tout le peuple mort
aiment le football puis la deuxième
raison quand même c'est que c'est pas
tout à fait la même fiscalité qu'en
france a
voté y en a pas on fait il y en a mais à
la source donc les salaires qui sont
versés sont en est
allé génial bon ben je crois qu'on va
faire une interview radin
alors guy ou est-ce que vous êtes radin
au point de ramasser une pièce de 10
centimes dans la rue
non parce que je pense que le tube d'alj
pan qu'il me faudrait pour mon tour de
rein coûterait plus cher que 10 centimes
est ce que vous êtes radar au point de
râler si ya pas de journaux gratuits
dans les avions quand vous montez
non je m'en veux quand je les ai dit
quand je suis arrivé en avance à
l'aérodrome et j'ai déjà acheté l'équipe
est calé dans le drame
est ce que vous êtes radio point de
récupérer les vêtements qu'on vous prête
quand vous tourner des publicités
ça m'arrive de temps je suis très pressé
de partir avec le côté où ça j'ai une
petite coquetterie de ce côté là est ce
que vous êtes radin au point de donner
des pouvoirs aux chauffeurs de taxi que
quand les notes sont remboursés non non
est ce que vous êtes trajet au point
interne le moteur de votre voiture en
descente je les fais à gedo quand
j'étais très pauvre en scooter jeu
toutes les descentes toutes les grandes
descentes gelé je lui faisais moteur
éteint et après avec ma quatre chevaux
aussi c'est vrai et pour les 2000
milliards de dettes qu'on a en france il
serait bien plus consensuel dire au
président il va nous apprendre la guy
roux président exactement est ce que
vous êtes trad à un point de demander à
vos joueurs de ne pas échanger leurs
maillots avec l'adversaire
non parce que les joueurs professionnels
presque dans tous les clubs payent les
maillons qui ne rendent pas ils ont deux
maillots parma et il ya un tableau et à
la fin du match on regarde ce qui n'est
pas rendu et on le retient la fin du
mois donc comme c'était comme c'était
souvent un bon prix j'étais plutôt pour
qu'ils échangent les maillots excuse est
radin auprès de mettre de l'eau du
robinet dans des bouteilles d'eau
minérale non jamais non parce que je
connais une très bonne eau
est ce que faisait le trajet au point
d'offrir des cadeaux promotionnels à vos
amis à noël jamet est ce que vous êtes
ravin au point d' économiser vos mots
pendant le commentaire d'un match ah non
là c'est il faut il faut dire tous les
mots nécessaires et pas trop parce qu'on
est deux enfin ta g et c'est difficile
et le consultant doit intervenir à bon
escient seulement quand on est à la télé
là par exemple là dans les loges là vous
vous repartez avec des fruits non
aujourd'hui elle pas de fruits mais
c'est vrai que ça m'est arrivé de
repartir avec les fleurs pour les offrir
il ya eu dans pool nantes alors y'a pas
de fleurs flux et les fruits oui pour le
pour la route oui comme madame de
fontenay les mariés excuse est radin au
point de faire des additions séparés
avec vos potes au resto c'est un usage
commun chez les journalistes qui m'a
surpris moi j'avais plutôt l'habitude
quand même de payer à manger aux copains
ou de me faire offrir est-ce que des
trades à un point de demander une
prostituée de vous rendre la monnaie
c'est pas un sport que je pratique vous
en trouvez pas non c'est trop cher
entre
non
et de trois quarts
je lis oui
alors qu'arte sélectionneur national
vous devez dire quels joueurs vous
auriez pris et pas pris à la place de
raymond domenech ah bon j'aurais pris
les mêmes gardiens de but lui
j'aurais pris djibril cissé et
boumsong parce que c'est des joueurs dos
qui ont joué à auxerre
j'aurai beaucoup hésité
entre ribéry et
pires
bon je vais vous faire une réponse quand
même de normanville ne propose pas
discuter joueur à joueur on va là c'est
mademoiselle est déjà fait
la foire vous parler technique
il y avait 18 joueurs indiscutables
après il y en avait 10 pour en faire
cinq alors il ya cinq malheureux il ya
julie par exemple qu'il est parti
en australie pour on le retrouve pas si
on avait besoin de lui y'a pires faille
à cinq malheureux ou là mais je trouve
que la sélection est raisonnable que on
appris ce qu'il y avait de meilleur de
presse meyer dans le football français
maintenant faut que l'amalgamé se fasse
qu'on est un peu de chance qu'on n'ait
pas de blessures chez les joueurs
majeurs et ça peut passer ça peut passer
ça peut passer on a d'abord une poule
assez faible pour s est faite de co doit
aller en huitièmes de finale normalement
on doit pouvoir battre la corée ou la
suisse et puis le togo qui est mal mal
préparé depuis longtemps
ensuite les huitièmes de finale on peut
avoir un adversaire à notre main à
partir des quarts de finale c'est déjà
bien la fois peu de chance quand même
ans on a gagné par exemple l'euro en
marquant
but en dernière minute on a gagné aux
penalties dans certains matchs donc là
on a ça ça a bien été pour nous faut que
ça aille bien pour nous encore et zidane
est arrivé et s'est blessé tout de suite
thierry henry s'est fait sortir bon là
ça pas bien tourné pour nous voilà
moi
c'est long
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux